...
-ECOUTE,
..ECOUTE,
..LE PRINTEMPS SUR LA COLLINE...
-T'appelle et mêle..
..sa gaieté à ma détresse.
Le temps s'en va
et les mois passent.
Depuis un an, j'espère..
..que tu reviennes prendre place..
..là où nos coeurs
vivaient naguère.
-Mes jours se traînent,
mes nuits s'étirent,
..et ma peine est profonde.
Où sont nos rêves ?
Où sont nos rires..
..sans toi..
..qui est au bout du monde ?
-ECOUTE, ECOUTE,
..LE PRINTEMPS SUR LA COLLINE...
-T'appelle..
..et mêle..
..sa gaieté à ma détresse.
-JE T'AIME, JE T'AIME,
..LE PRINTEMPS SUR LA COLLINE...
-T'attend, viens-t'en..
..que notre bonheur renaisse.
-CAR IL N'EST
DE BEAUX JOURS SANS AMOURS.
-Combien de mois
et de semaines..
..devrais-je encore attendre..
..pour que le destin te ramène..
..réduisant
nos chagrins en cendres ?
-Tu es ma chance,
tu es ma flamme,
..la force qui me guide.
Reviens-moi vite,
reviens mon âme.
Sans toi..
..la maison semble vide.
-ECOUTE, ECOUTE,
..LE PRINTEMPS SUR LA COLLINE...
-T'appelle..
..et mêle..
..sa gaieté..
..à ma détresse.
-JE T'AIME, JE T'AIME,
..LE PRINTEMPS SUR LA COLLINE...
-T'attend, viens-t'en..
..que notre bonheur renaisse.
-CAR IL N'EST DE BEAUX JOURS..
..SANS AMOURS.
...